ultra endurance sports didn't just
change me physically they actually gave
me a brand new life throughout my 30s I
was climbing the corporate ladder very
intent on achieving the traditional idea
of the American Dream but deep down
inside I started to question this path
that I was on for well over a decade I
really hadn't been taking care of myself
I had become a junk food addict I was 50
pounds overweight kind of semi depressed
and shortly before I turned 40 I was
climbing up a simple flight of stairs to
go to bed one evening and I had to pause
halfway I was winded I was out of breath
I tightness in my chest and it was a
very specific moment in time in which I
realized not only that I needed to
change my lifestyle habits but that I
had the willingness that I truly wanted
to I realized that vague ideas of eating
better or working out a little bit or
going to the gym weren't really going to
work for me I needed something specific
something definitive I played around
with a bunch of different diets to no
avail and I sort of attempted this
experiment in plant-based eating as kind
of the last thing that I hadn't explored
and I didn't have a big expectation that
it would make a big difference but
within about seven to ten days of eating
nothing but plants nothing with a mother
nothing with a face I experienced this
extraordinary thing like I had this
resurgence in vitality my mental acuity
improved my sleep improved I had this
sense of well-being and energy that I
hadn't really felt since I was a
teenager and I didn't really know what I
was doing but I knew in that moment that
I was on to something and it started
getting me thinking about human
potential and my own potential because
if I could make such a simple basic
shift and experience such a dramatic
result where were there other untapped
reservoirs of potential that I could
explore and that's what got me
interested ultimately in the world of
ultra endurance sports at the peak of
training I would say I was training
about 25 hours a week so it was really
almost a second job and at the time I
was still a practicing attorney I have
four kids I'm busy doing a lot of things
and in order to
make the time that was required to
appropriately prepare for this race I
had to make some significant cuts and
really look hard and fast at how I was
spending my time on a day to day basis I
had to get rid of late night television
and sort of business meetings that could
be pushed to a conference call or an
email chain free up the time that was
required so I could show up at the
starting line and know in my heart of
hearts that I could complete this race I
started training which really connected
me with myself in a very profound way
and to the surprise of myself and many
other people I ended up showing some
prowess in this field and ended up
competing at a very high level
specifically a race called Ultraman
which is a double Ironman distance
triathlon over the course of three days
completely circumnavigates the entire
Big Island of Hawaii
[Music]